[Música]
mi adicción es mi culpa
321 ahora
demonios
memoria consumir muchas drogas en mis
primeros años de desarrollo así que si
es mi culpa podrías hablar de que fue
culpa de mis genes que estos hicieran
que tomar las pastillas o que las
pusiera ni cuerpo podría pensar eso
existe un componente genético que no
está bajo mi control ni de mi familia es
la razón por la que estoy aquí no porque
ahora estoy sobrio es
extraño porque al principio no sé si lo
estaba pero ahora si decido tomar un
trago o si decido otro Carmen se lo que
hago se lo que estoy haciendo y según lo
que me estoy metiendo es mi decisión si
quiero continuar drogándome o lo que sea
nadie me apunta con un arma y me hace
tomar algún trago otro por esa razón
estoy de acuerdo el consumir una droga
es mi decisión
es el ambiente por qué algunas personas
nacen en hogares donde los padres sufren
de adicción a las drogas o son
alcohólicos y en vecindarios más
desfavorecidos como de dónde vengo se ve
muchas madres que consiguen una dosis en
tan solo 30 minutos y frente a sus hijos
sufro de esta adicción por salir a
fiestas ahora el alcohol cuenta como si
estuviera limpia 10 demonios ni siquiera
puedo decir que estoy sobre bien está
bien de acuerdo como sea así así que
siento que salgo de autocontrol de la
influencia del ambiente pero pienso que
en gran parte para mí es autocontrol
porque siendo honesta si pones una línea
de cocaína frente a mí en este momento
voy a inhalar la saben es así pienso que
yo inicie lo que sufro sufro de adicción
a la comida alerta de spoiler para que
todos sepan cuando era más joven tuve
más oportunidades de recuperarme de
verme y sentirme mejor tomado ventaja de
todo me faltaba la
varias veces
yo pienso que la adicción no es una
enfermedad creo que es más como una
convicción porque el decir que es una
enfermedad significa que se propaga por
lo tanto personalmente mi droga favorita
son los alucinógenos así que si
estuviera drogada eso quiere decir que
te estás contagiado tú tú y tú creo que
es algo genético la manera como la
adicción se da en nosotros o como el
alcoholismo se da en mi familia y es
extraño ver personas que digan soy el
único en mi familia que está sonriendo
desde el principio como desde tu
nacimiento como si solo fueras estoy
estuviera frente al final no lo sé lo
que dices no lo sabe amigo eso fue algo
que yo no no es una elección y si
hubiese sido así no estaría aquí cada
día mi cerebro trata de asesinarme y eso
es lo que sucede pero tengo que vivir
con ellos no quisiera pero lo sufro no
sé qué es lo que piensen pero el pensar
yo como una enfermedad nunca me ha
ayudado si puedes estar predispuesto por
los fines pero lo que me ha ayudado es
la medicina y la información Alcohólicos
Anónimos nunca me ayudó porque te dicen
solo probaste esto y nunca me conecte
con eso y créeme quería conectar
referirse a ella como una enfermedad es
como asociar a todos en este ámbito en
una situación negativa si te mantiene
esa palabra me siento identificado no
hay nada bueno o malo en esto creo que
cada uno tiene su criterio
compararlo con las enfermedades del
corazón por qué no eliges tenerlas la
genética tiene mucho que ver con ella y
también el estilo de vida quiero decir
eso son básicamente los ingredientes de
la fórmula de una enfermedad de todos
modos quiero decir que las enfermedades
del corazón no son contagiosas tampoco
lo es la adicción pero creo que es
totalmente una enfermedad cuando se
habla de cómo afecta la gente como se
presenta como empieza creo que mucho es
muy similar las drogas de entrada son
una cosa real
centro gas de entrada
peso como sea
de filete loca de entrada
todos los que han consumido alguna droga
literalmente tienen una droga que
consumieron antes entonces te refieres a
la droga de entrada a las drogas que te
llevan a otras drogas yo diría que sí
que sí creo que puede ser una cadena
Tato temeroso y fumas hierba puede que
consumas heroína en algún momento de tu
vida cómo puede que no creo que eso
sería algo bueno para mí sería como sí
pero no si fumas hierba estás perdido
también es por eso que muchas personas
no son completamente adictas a la
heroína aunque haya recibido pedazos de
primera calidad en el hospital durante
una operación quiero decir no es una
droga de entrada no entra si dices oye
probado eso tengo que consumir heroína
ahora no lo haces quiero decir estás
perdiendo esa razón vital para perseguir
la droga si te la dan para el dolor real
en el hospital no decides que quieres
salir y consumir heroína cuándo terminas
quiero decir la mayoría de las personas
no lo hace yo sé
me siento cómodo siendo etiquetado como
un adicto
321 ahora
sí sí sí
personalmente siento que no me gusta que
me llamen adicto como alguien que va
caminando por la calle ella consume
drogas siento que si tú todo el mundo
tiene algo en lo que participa y siento
que etiquetar a alguien así es
moralmente ofensivo sí creo que también
que te Carlo como 3 días para sentirme
bien y volver a beber eso es muy
efectivo eso no es salir de fiesta eso
es atragantarse con Boca por la mañana y
si me siento mal por ello y me parece
bien sentirme mal por ella es lo que
creo no importa un cuerno como me llame
la gente
quiero decir soy una porquería sabes lo
que quiero decir pero no me define como
persona sino que es parte de lo que soy
así que ya saben no me importa y como
dijiste si conozco a alguien y me dice
oye estoy luchando con esto yo soy del
tipo oye yo también siento lo mismo
entonces realmente ayuda entonces ya
saben puedo decir vaya yo hice eso y así
es como lo afronte sí pero fíjate en
cómo lo has dicho que oye estoy luchando
con esto soy un adicto ya sabes suena
mucho más duro y creo que es la
connotación negativa ya sabes te estás
poniendo en esa categoría
campo te estás poniendo en una categoría
y ninguna persona debería ponerse en
oposición mental solo porque eso es lo
que otras personas quieren que hagas
simplemente no doy
yo sé que estoy en una minoría de es que
realmente no me llaman la atención me
recuerda que soy una Tito y yo no lo
recuerdo un día me engañó diciendo que
no soy un adicto y entonces salgo a
drogarme mi amigo no tiene ningún
problema así que estoy bien con que me
recuerden que soy un adicto porque así
es como ellos lo perciben pero no me
importa
he perdido a alguien debido a la
adicción
321 ahora
no conozco nada de que haya muerto por
una sobredosis o sorprendentemente
conozco mucha gente que probablemente lo
hará en un futuro no muy lejano pero aún
no conozco a nadie eso no es solo tengo
24 ya veremos a qué es muy importante
tener en cuenta el hecho de que
mi primer amigo falleció
lo lamento
lo siento
si mi amigo falleció por una sobredosis
fue hace 11 años hace 6 días y asumi la
responsabilidad porque
yo lo otro que por primera vez con
éxtasis y por primera vez con opiáceos y
eso fue una llamada de atención para mí
decidí ir a rehabilitación
perdí más de 30 amigos por suicidio o
adicción
conozco muchos casos cuando entré en
recuperación fue algo que no esperaba mi
vida mejoro y empecé a construir
relaciones con las personas y
acercándome más a ellos y se
convirtieron en mis mejores amigos y
empezaron a caer uno a uno cuando mi
primer amigo murió me tatúe su imagen
pero luego no pude seguir haciéndome
tatuajes por los amigos que fallecieron
lo siento
los programas de rehabilitación y
recuperación funcionan
321 ahora
tengo una amiga que ha estado en
rehabilitación hospitalaria cinco veces
en los últimos tres años y está mejor
pero
las cuatro primeras seguro que no
funcionaron así que no creo que
necesariamente sea una forma infalible
de curar a alguien que tiene una
adicción a algo no hay formas infalibles
de hacer nada y si quieres realmente
discutible funcionen para toneladas de
personas por supuesto que funcionan
hacen cosas increíbles si lo quieres
irás por las herramientas que necesitas
para construir la comunidad que
requieres entonces puedes permanecer
sobrio pero si no no funciona y punto si
si pudiera vivir en rehabilitación lo
haría porque todos como son como te
despiertas a esta hora comes a esta hora
hablas de tus sentimientos a esa hora y
luego cuando sales es como no es no es
fácil y eso carece de estructura y es
raro pero te ayuda a obtener las
herramientas para saber cómo navegar por
esta vida pero si no están ahí contigo
el tiempo ya sabes es cosa tuya con
quién hablas de tus sentimientos con
quién hablo cuando sales cuando estoy ya
sabes con todos ustedes nos encanta
oírlo
más bien en el lado del desacuerdo
porque estoy de acuerdo con ustedes en
que hay que querer estar sobrio tal vez
no quiere estar sobrio al 100% en este
momento pero los programas que he
probado he probado la hospitalización he
probado el asesoramiento he intentado
con la comunidad muchos de ellos son muy
cerrados y muy cerrados me refiero a que
este grupo se asocia con este grupo eres
un marginado es como un episodio de
Miguel y así por eso debería haber más
estructura debería haber más puestos de
trabajos abiertos en esta instalación
con personas tiene licencia para influir
en los demás y hacer que quieran hacer
algo mejor dime por qué debería estar
sobrio amar mi vida dejar de hacer lo
que estoy haciendo y no siento que los
programas de sustitución al menos a los
que yo fui me hayan inculcado eso es mi
opinión tengo un desacuerdo con las
instituciones de recuperación la forma
que lo hacen en Los Ángeles pero creo
que al final si la persona realmente
quiere estar sobre y liberarse de la
adicción
un lugar con buena reputación que ha
ayudado a alguien antes y asimilan todo
eso y aprende nuevas herramientas para
mantenerse sobrios en lugar de drogarse
[Música]
gracias
Jubilee vive intensamente